michael harbor here we go  what advice would you give to a comedian  on how to improve if they only do one  mic a week  do more than one mic a week  i mean  listen on the podcast i've interviewed  over 400 comedians and the number one  piece of advice  has been you've got to get on stage  that is where you exercise the language  of comedies think comedy is a language  and the stage is your immersion  and yeah like i do have classes and  workshops that help people learn the  different writing techniques and how to  really shorten that learning curve  but you have to take what you've learned  and you have to take it to the stage  like the stage is literally that is  where  you learn  everything you need to know it's by  doing  and hop earth podcast of course